Hey, I'm Josh Radner, and I am joined as ever by my dear friend, Craig Thomas.
嘿，我是乔什·拉德纳，我亲爱的朋友克雷格·托马斯一如既往地加入我的行列。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
It's great to see you again.
很高兴再次见到你。
This is a bonus episode of how we made your mother, and it's something we like to call general questions.
这是我们如何创造你母亲的额外一集，我们喜欢将其称为一般性问题。
General questions.
一般问题。
So we're joined also by our pal and producer Alec Lev.
我们的朋友兼制片人亚历克·列夫也加入了我们。
Hello Alec.
你好亚历克。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hello.
你好。
Do you have any general questions for us?
您有任何一般性问题要问我们吗？
I am honest, my man.
我很诚实，伙计。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
All right.
好的。
You missed your salute, Craig.
你错过了你的敬礼，克雷格。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
Excellent.
出色的。
Oh, awful.
哦，太糟糕了。
Yeah.
是的。
So I was never in the army.
所以我从来没有参过军。
I never will be in the army.
我永远不会参军。
Yeah.
是的。
Hi, guys.
嗨，大家好。
This week, people are curious, I would say, in the large about how TV kind of gets made.
我想说，本周，人们对电视是如何制作的非常好奇。
There's a lot of questions.
有很多问题。
And by the way, this is about episode three sweet taste of liberty.
顺便说一句，这是关于第三集的《自由的甜蜜滋味》。
These are questions about episode three, right?
这些是关于第三集的问题，对吧？
It is, that is correct.
是的，这是正确的。
There were a lot of questions about Liberty Bells and licking things, and we're gonna focus more on the production side of things.
关于自由钟和舔东西有很多问题，我们将更多地关注事情的制作方面。
I'm just gonna give you a couple examples, but then I'm gonna kind of broaden out the question.
我只想给你举几个例子，然后我会扩大这个问题的范围。
So, LJ spectrum asks, how far into filming did you create the opening sequence and bar photos?
那么，LJ Spectrum 问道，您是在拍摄多久后才创作开场镜头和酒吧照片的？
Was it specifically for this episode and then turned into the opening montage?
是专门为了这一集然后变成开场蒙太奇吗？
How did you do that?
你是怎么做到的？
And then Oscar underscore Cal Vajor says just out of curiosity is this the same basement we see later on at Stella's house.
然后奥斯卡强调卡尔·瓦乔出于好奇说这就是我们后来在斯特拉家看到的同一个地下室。
So just thinking about how, yeah, I don't know, but the answer to that or what?
所以只是想一下如何，是的，我不知道，但是答案是什么？
I've never actually seen this show.
我从来没有真正看过这个节目。
I don't have any, I have no answers to any of this.
我没有任何答案，我对此没有任何答案。
I heard it so, obviously we have viewers who know a lot more than we do.
我是这么听的，显然我们有比我们懂得更多的观众。
But I think what this is going to is just kind How do you make a television show?
但我认为这只是善意的 你如何制作电视节目？
And I think if we can walk through one thing, we'll answer a lot of people's questions.
我认为如果我们能够解决一件事，我们就能回答很多人的问题。
And maybe we could do a helium style of, how did Craig see a week of production and how did Josh see a week of production?
也许我们可以做一个氦气风格的，克雷格如何看待一周的制作以及乔希如何看待一周的制作？
How was this show made?
这个节目是怎么制作的？
Can I go back to a thing?
我可以回到一件事吗？
Because I actually, I really like the first question about the open credit sequence.
因为我实际上非常喜欢关于开放信用序列的第一个问题。
Me too.
我也是。
Great, great.
太棒了，太棒了。
So, and we can get back to this out because I like this too, but Craig, where did the idea for the opening credits This is kind of like friends, pictures, kind of popular.
所以，我们可以回到这个话题，因为我也喜欢这个，但是克雷格，片头的想法是从哪里来的？这有点像朋友、图片，很受欢迎。
That was from the beginning.
从一开始就是如此。
That was when we were writing the pilot, when the pilot got picked up.
那是我们在写试播集的时候，试播集被选中的时候。
We always had that idea.
我们一直有这个想法。
This is a weird thing that I don't think I've ever talked about.
这是一件奇怪的事情，我想我从来没有谈论过。
For a minute, I remember Carter Bay's, I think it might have been his concept to begin with.
有那么一瞬间，我想起了卡特·贝的想法，我想这可能是他最初的想法。
And the way he wanted to do it at first was pictures of just young people in New York, not even our cast.
他一开始想要的只是纽约年轻人的照片，甚至不是我们的演员。
This very abstracted idea of like, you're just seeing youth in New York.
这个非常抽象的想法，就像你在纽约看到的年轻人一样。
It could be anyone.
可以是任何人。
seeing this pastiche of New York City and people out.
看到纽约市和外面的人们的模仿。
And it's just them and their friends, blah, blah, blah.
只有他们和他们的朋友，等等，等等。
And I think we gained it out.
我认为我们已经成功了。
We started looking at it, we're like, this is too weird.
我们开始观察它，我们想，这太奇怪了。
Who are these people?
这些人是谁？
These aren't the same.
这些并不相同。
I mean, this is in the cast of the show.
我的意思是，这是节目的演员阵容。
And that was how we learned.
这就是我们学习的方式。
I mean, it was sort of a little too artsy of an idea, maybe.
我的意思是，这个想法也许有点太艺术化了。
And then we realized, let's get the cast to do this.
然后我们意识到，让演员们来做这件事吧。
But if I remember, currently, Josh, I think we did the pilot, right?
但如果我记得的话，乔什，我想我们现在已经完成了试播，对吧？
We did a little photo shoot.
我们拍了一些照片。
We did a photo shoot right away.
我们立即拍了一张照片。
Like in the booth, kind of like Candid's.
就像在展位上一样，有点像 Candid 的。
I remember, did Jason hold the camera?
我记得杰森拿着相机吗？
Was it like a selfie?
是不是像一张自拍照？
I think sometimes you guys were selfieing and I think sometimes literally Pam Fryman, our director, I think was like shooting it on at what at that time was like a crappy like disposable camera.
我想有时你们在自拍，有时我们的导演帕姆·弗莱曼(Pam ​​Fryman)，我认为就像用当时像一次性相机一样蹩脚的相机来拍摄。
These were on phone packs, right?
这些是在手机包装上，对吗？
And you see that Lily, it looks, and it dates the show so much, but you see in titles that Lily is holding that old disposable camera.
你看莉莉，它看起来，而且它与这部剧过时了很多，但你在标题中看到莉莉拿着那台旧的一次性相机。
That's literally what they're still getting.
这确实是他们仍然得到的。
So they're placed on tables at weddings, you know, there's still in use.
所以它们被放在婚礼的桌子上，你知道，它们仍然在使用。
Ironically.
讽刺的是。
Where the like color scheme come up with like that kind of seepia, so I really like the kind of rods and yellows and.
类似的配色方案就像那种渗色，所以我真的很喜欢那种棒状和黄色。
We said we wanted to feel like memories, like these sort of old tinge sort of like seepia tone, sort of like just this feeling of these exist as memories in someone's mind.
我们说我们想要感觉像回忆，就像这种古老的色调，有点像渗水的音调，有点像这些感觉作为记忆存在于某人的脑海中。
Yeah.
是的。
And when did you guys hit on using the solid song or the end of Hey Beautiful?
你们什么时候开始使用这首扎实的歌曲或《Hey Beautiful》的结尾？
I think we, for a minute, we wanted to use, I've never said this either, I think, we wanted to use a replacement song.
我想我们，有一分钟，我们想使用，我也从来没有说过这个，我想，我们想使用一首替代歌曲。
The band replacement, Carter and I are huge fans replacements card turned me into a replacement span.
乐队的替换，卡特和我都是巨大的粉丝替换卡，把我变成了替换跨度。
And we were talking about using, um, I think we're going to, I think we're going to use the song unsatisfied.
我们正在讨论使用，嗯，我想我们会，我想我们会不满意地使用这首歌。
Like, and literally, I think we cut a version of the main titles that was pictures of total strangers set to the replacement song unsatisfied.
就像，从字面上看，我认为我们剪掉了一个主要标题的版本，该版本是完全陌生的照片，设置为替换歌曲不满意。
It looks like it's just opening titles to an entirely different show called unsatisfied.
看起来这只是一个完全不同的节目《不满意》的开头。
It was utterly confusing and it was a complete fail, but it's what taught us that we needed it to be our cast.
这完全令人困惑，而且完全失败，但它告诉我们，我们需要它作为我们的演员阵容。
And the idea of photos and memories like that, that was always the idea, but we had to do a bad like misguided version of that to get to what it became.
像这样的照片和回忆的想法，这一直是我们的想法，但我们必须做一个像误导版本那样的坏事才能达到它的目的。
And isn't Barney's last name after a guitar like a replacement?
巴尼的姓氏是不是就像吉他的替代品一样？
Yeah, Barney Stinson.
是的，巴尼·斯汀森。
Stinson, Tommy Stinson is the bass player for the replacements, and that is a shout out to the replacements.
Stinson，汤米·斯廷森（Tommy Stinson）是替代者的贝斯手，这是对替代者的大声疾呼。
Who again, and we really wanted to unsatisfied to be the song, and then we got the bill for what that would cost every week.
又是谁，我们真的很不满意成为这首歌，然后我们每周都会收到费用的账单。
And then we said, what if we put our own band song on there, And we get that money.
然后我们说，如果我们把我们自己的乐队歌曲放在那里，我们就能得到这笔钱。
And they said, what about one tenth of that money?
他们说，那十分之一的钱呢？
I said souls.
我说灵魂。
Craig, did you need to get approval at this point?
克雷格，此时你需要获得批准吗？
Did the studio or network have to like, look at that title sequence?
工作室或网络是否必须喜欢看那个标题序列？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That thing is like tested and game down and sent up and down the chain.
那东西就像经过测试和游戏，并在链条上上下发送。
It's, it's, it's the branding of the show, right?
这是，这是，这是节目的品牌，对吧？
It's like the brand does become so iconic.
就好像这个品牌确实变得如此具有标志性。
And what's amazing about it now is like, I see people online.
现在令人惊奇的是，我看到人们在线。
I see people on socials like them and their friends are literally shot for shot recreating how I met your mother photos from the opening main titles and they're doing it with their own friends.
我看到像他们这样的社交媒体上的人和他们的朋友一起拍摄，重现我如何遇见你母亲的照片，他们是和自己的朋友一起做的。
And I find that so moving and pointing like we've passed this baton onto this younger generation who are now like enacting it.
我发现这非常令人感动和具有指向性，就像我们已经将接力棒传递给了年轻一代，他们现在正在执行它。
And it's their way of saying we're making our own memories now I think which is a story that Josh you've told to about a fan told you said do you I realize I'm living these memories now and that's I love the idea that like young people watching the show are creating that themselves.
这是他们说我们现在正在创造我们自己的回忆的方式，我想这是你给乔什讲过的一个关于粉丝告诉你的故事，你说我意识到我现在正在经历这些回忆，这就是我喜欢这样的想法，就像观看节目的年轻人正在创造自己的回忆一样。
Yeah.
是的。
So speaking of memories.
所以说到回忆。
So Josh, so at this point when week three of producing this show, obviously spread over time between the pilot and the second episode, but what was your week like, at least in this first season, how did that script first come to on what day rehearsal blocking?
所以乔什，所以在制作这个节目的第三周，显然随着时间的推移在试播集和第二集之间传播，但是你的一周是什么样的，至少在第一季，这个剧本是如何在排练的哪一天第一次出现的？
How did it look for you?
你觉得怎么样？
My memory is in Craig maybe like we would get an envelope over the weekend.
我的记忆在克雷格身上，也许我们周末会收到一个信封。
Yeah, like on a Sunday, I think maybe sometimes Friday, sometimes Friday, but hard copies in a in a Manila envelope kind of like waiting at your door.
是的，就像周日一样，我想有时可能是周五，有时是周五，但硬拷贝装在马尼拉信封里，就像在你家门口等着一样。
Yeah, and you'd read and that was the table script.
是的，您已经读过，这就是表格脚本。
That was the script we were going to read Monday at like 10 a.m.
这就是我们周一上午 10 点左右要读的剧本。
Correct.
正确的。
So the actors would come in at 10 a.m.
所以演员们会在上午 10 点进来。
on Monday.
周一。
We'd sit around a table.
我们围坐在一张桌子旁。
There was a great spread of food.
有很多食物。
All the writers were where their producers, the department heads would come to that.
所有的编剧都在他们的制片人那里，部门主管也会来处理这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
And we'd like to get around this.
我们想解决这个问题。
Yeah, we, the studio execs network execs, we'd sit around and it was, it was not a high pressure.
是的，我们，工作室高管和网络高管，我们会坐在一起，这并不是一个高压。
I never felt beyond maybe the pilot table read.
我从来没有感觉到除了飞行员表上的读数之外。
That was always like the chillest low pressure kind of thing.
这总是像最寒冷的低压之类的事情。
So we'd read the script, Pam would read the stage directions and you and Carter would flank Pam, I remember.
我记得，我们会读剧本，帕姆会读舞台指示，而你和卡特会在帕姆两侧。
Yeah.
是的。
And by the way, just to say counterpoint, I was wildly nervous for all 200 native tables.
顺便说一句，我对所有 200 个本地表都感到非常紧张。
You were.
你是。
Okay.
好的。
Well, miserably anxious.
嗯，焦急万分。
I shocked that you weren't.
我很震惊你不是。
But think about writer brand.
但想想作家品牌。
Think about writer brand versus actor brand.
想想作家品牌与演员品牌。
But they will read all about the script.
但他们会阅读有关剧本的所有内容。
I mean, it's about performance, but we weren't.
我的意思是，这与性能有关，但我们不是。
People were listening to the script.
人们正在听剧本。
They weren't even watching us read it.
他们甚至没有看我们读它。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
They were listening to it in the air.
他们在空中听着。
It was like a radio play.
这就像一部广播剧。
To me, I'd always felt like a high stakes courtroom trial for the script.
对我来说，我一直觉得剧本就像是一场高风险的法庭审判。
And like the script, the script might be like executed at the end of it.
就像脚本一样，脚本可能会在最后执行。
I always fought a pit in my stomach.
我总是在与胃里的一个坑作斗争。
It was great when it went great, but- What's the thing where writers will write down if they think a joke is good, but do they just write P for performance?
进展顺利时很棒，但是——如果作家认为一个笑话很好，他们会写下什么，但他们写P只是为了表演吗？
The P means punch it.
P的意思是打它。
P means punch in writer's opinion.
P的意思是表达作者的观点。
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
So what are the things that you're struggling with?
那么你正在努力解决哪些问题呢？
Were you say, that was the actress fault, not mine.
你是说，那是女演​​员的错，不是我的错。
I don't know that there's a universal code for that.
我不知道有一个通用代码。
I heard there was something where you write in like, bad line reading, like, good joke.
我听说有一些东西你可以写，比如，读不好的台词，比如，好笑话。
Or something like, we should say that- That's, that's also writers being fucking dicks, right?
或者类似的话，我们应该说——也就是说，这也是作家们他妈的混蛋，对吧？
It was definitely the actor's fall.
这绝对是演员的堕落。
Like, I don't know about that.
比如说，我对此一无所知。
And some writers do that.
有些作家就是这样做的。
So we would read, it would be done by 1045, no later than 11.
所以我们会读到，它将在 1045 之前完成，不迟于 11 点。
Yeah.
是的。
We go home for the rest of the day.
这一天剩下的时间我们就回家了。
The actor's leave.
演员请假。
You can just say one thing about the table read, sorry, as someone who just sat in on some of them.
抱歉，作为一个刚刚旁听了其中一些的人，您可以就桌子上的内容说一件事。
You say it wasn't for the actor's room for the script.
你说这不是演员的剧本房间。
Certainly for me who had no stake in this spot, so ever, it was a, it was such a joy to listen to the radio play version of it, because you guys maybe because the pressure was so low, you guys were so loose.
当然，对于我来说，这个地方没有任何利害关系，所以，听广播剧版本真是太高兴了，因为你们可能是因为压力太低了，你们太放松了。
Yeah, you guys were great.
是的，你们很棒。
Having so much fun.
玩得很开心。
And it's the one time where the show is not about the, what becomes the great direction, the great production, the great sound.
这是一场演出不再是伟大的方向、伟大的制作、伟大的声音的一次。
It's just about the five of you talking to each other.
就是你们五个人互相交谈。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was hysterical.
这是歇斯底里的。
It was always, it was great.
一直都是这样，太棒了。
It was great vibes.
气氛很棒。
I was anxious because I'm crazy and I'm a writer and I'm neurotic about the writing being good enough that the vibes were great in the room.
我很焦虑，因为我疯了，我是一名作家，我对写作是否足够好以至于房间里的氛围很棒感到神经质。
I've never been in a better table reads than how I'm in the 20th table.
我从来没有遇到过比第 20 名表更好的读表情况。
As you guys are great at it, loose and funny, it was great.
你们很擅长，轻松又有趣，这太棒了。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back's the show.
现在，节目又回来了。
I always love the tapery.
我永远喜欢挂毯。
I always loved, you know, You grab like a little bit of melon, maybe a bagel, a little smear, and you sit down, you just be so relaxed, and especially the more you do it, you're so relaxed at the table.
我一直喜欢，你知道，你抓起一点瓜，也许是百吉饼，一点涂抹，然后你坐下来，你就变得如此放松，尤其是你做得越多，你在餐桌上就越放松。
Yeah.
是的。
You guys were uniquely relaxed and had fun with it in a way that's not always true, to be honest.
老实说，你们特别放松，并且以一种并不总是如此的方式享受其中。
You guys were really good at that.
你们真的很擅长这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
And then, well, at some point you stop feeling like you're auditioning, and you're like, I have the gig.
然后，好吧，在某个时刻，你不再感觉自己在试镜，你会想，我得到了演出机会。
It's been on the air.
它已经在播出了。
The ratings are good.
收视率都不错。
I have the gig.
我有演出。
I'm really hard to recast me at this point.
我现在真的很难重塑自己。
Yeah.
是的。
season eight.
第八季。
Yeah.
是的。
So, so then we leave, but you guys stay and rewrite the script the rest of the day, based on that.
那么，我们就离开了，但你们留下来，并在此基础上重写当天剩下的剧本。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
Oh, yes, we would.
哦，是的，我们会的。
You guys would be like, great, I had breakfast.
你们会说，太好了，我吃过早餐了。
I'm going to go, I'm going to go workout.
我要走了，我要去锻炼身体。
I'm going to go do thing.
我要去办事了
I'm like, all right, we're going to be able to team in the morning, tearing our hair out.
我想，好吧，我们明天早上就可以组队，尽情发挥。
We would stay, Monday nights were not always super laid for the writers, but yeah, we would, we'd be there.
我们会留下来，周一晚上对于作家来说并不总是超级舒服，但是，是的，我们会，我们会在那里。
We'd be there for dinner.
我们会在那里吃晚饭。
We'd be there going line by line, making it as good as we could knowing there was a run through it for the next more, the next We would get a script maybe that night, sometimes late, sometimes late, sometimes I'd wake up Tuesday morning and just see the manila and the little by my front door.
我们会一行一行地在那里，尽可能地知道接下来还有一个剧本，下一个我们可能会在那天晚上得到一个剧本，有时很晚，有时很晚，有时我周二早上醒来，只看到马尼拉和我前门边的小东西。
Yeah.
是的。
God bless the PAs.
上帝保佑 PA。
God bless the PAs driving those scripts around LA, like Christmas, Elvis leaving out your doorstep.
上帝保佑 PA 在洛杉矶推动这些剧本，就像圣诞节一样，猫王离开了你的家门口。
Yeah.
是的。
Wasn't it also funny?
是不是也很搞笑呢？
I hope Jason won't mind me saying this, but sometimes Jason during the table reads would laugh so loud at something that it was clear.
我希望杰森不会介意我这么说，但有时杰森在读表时会因为一些显而易见的事情而笑得很大声。
It was the first time he was reading it.
这是他第一次读它。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
It was very clear.
情况非常清楚。
And it was weird because it was like, oh, that was great.
这很奇怪，因为它就像，哦，那太棒了。
It's a real compliment to the work.
这是对这项工作的真正赞美。
I think maybe he should have read it by now.
我想也许他现在应该已经读过了。
But okay, like you were like you were excited that he was laughing like that.
但是好吧，就像你因为他那样笑而感到兴奋一样。
It was clearly discovering it in the moment what his character was doing.
很明显，他的角色在做什么的那一刻就被发现了。
And giving a great offent and giving a great like cold read, yeah.
是的，给予很大的冒犯和冷读。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I know he's in me.
我知道他在我心里。
He knew we could do that.
他知道我们可以做到。
But yeah, that was, I guess, that was the thing.
但是，是的，我想，就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
But it was a very generous laugh.
但这是一种非常慷慨的笑声。
You'd get the script and it would have asterisks on the, it would be a different color pages, right?
你会得到脚本，上面会有星号，它会是不同的颜色页面，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
you get the script and how the asterisks where all the changes had been revision marks for the previous, right?
你得到了脚本，星号中的所有更改都是以前的修订标记，对吗？
So did you ever did your heart sink when you when you found one that was like just machine gun fire asterisks all the way down?
那么，当你发现一个像机关枪射击的星号一样一直向下时，你的心是否曾经沉下去过？
You're like, ooh, well, it was really like you guys cracked it like you solved the thing.
你就像，哦，好吧，就像你们解决了问题一样。
Yeah, no other times, other times there were a few episodes where I felt like you guys were really chasing it like really you had you wrote three scripts in three days.
是的，没有其他时候，其他时候有几集我觉得你们真的在追逐它，就像你们真的在三天内写了三个剧本一样。
Did you ever get one and you're like really no asterisks here?
你是否曾经得到过一个，却感觉这里真的没有星号？
You're sticking with that one.
你坚持那个。
But there were also there were also you go through and you you kind of feel like, oh, maybe I blew that joke and now that joke is gone.
但也有一些时候，你也经历过，你会觉得，哦，也许我搞砸了那个笑话，现在那个笑话已经消失了。
Like sometimes you get self conscious.
就像有时你会变得自我意识一样。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, like I thought I didn't blow that joke.
好吧，就像我以为我没有开那个玩笑一样。
Why is that joke gone?
那个笑话怎么没了？
That oh, well, I would say nine times out of ten.
哦，好吧，我十有八九会这么说。
It's just right or self hatred.
这只是对的或自我憎恨。
It's just right.
恰到好处。
It's going the joke was no good.
看来这个玩笑开得不好。
It would If you like slightly fumble the joke, but it was good, we knew it, we would leave it in.
如果你喜欢稍微弄错这个笑话，但它很好，我们知道，我们会把它留下来。
I think it was probably much more direct.
我认为这可能更直接。
It was never too strong.
它从来都不是太强。
Most of the time it was an upgrade like it was really, especially so we would get the script.
大多数时候，这都是一次升级，尤其是这样我们就能得到脚本。
You drive back to the Foxot like around, I don't know, 9 or 10, we'd start.
你开车回到福克斯特，我不知道，九点或十点左右，我们就出发了。
I think we started a little earlier on Tuesday, 9 or 13.
我想我们周二九点或十三点开始得早一些。
I think we're rehearsing until kind of lunch time run through.
我想我们正在排练直到午餐时间结束。
Yeah, so that's just Pam and the cast and the props, they're all kicking around.
是的，所以只有帕姆、演员和道具，他们都在忙着。
the stage is buzzing, but you basically, we all clock down in the living room.
舞台上很热闹，但基本上，我们都在客厅打卡。
We'd read the script, we'd read the rewrite, Pam would have us read it, and then she would get us on our feet and we'd start staging it.
我们会读剧本，我们会读重写，帕姆会让我们读它，然后她会让我们站起来，我们就开始上演。
Sometimes you or Carter were there for that initial one if there were like a lot of rewrites, but mostly you just let us do it, right?
有时，如果有很多重写，你或卡特就会在那里进行最初的修改，但大多数情况下你只是让我们这样做，对吗？
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
We didn't want to be, we didn't want to be in the way over thinking the words you guys had to get it in your their bodies and start moving it through space and stuff.
我们不想成为这样的人，我们不想妨碍你们去思考那些话，你们必须把它带入你们的身体，并开始在空间和其他东西中移动它。
So Pam would stage the whole thing for, you know, then we'd have lunch.
所以帕姆会把整个事情安排好，然后我们就吃午饭。
And then after lunch, the stage would, all the writers, studio executives, network executives, all the department heads, everyone would descend upon the stage and we would run through at around 1230 or 1.
午饭后，舞台上，所有的编剧、工作室主管、网络主管、所有部门主管，每个人都会走上舞台，我们会在 1230 或 1 左右跑完。
Yeah.
是的。
And we'd run through the whole show and I remember Pam would say, all right, follow me down to the bar.
我们看完了整个演出，我记得帕姆会说，好吧，跟我到酒吧去。
Yeah, all the sets lined up on the stage, all the sets and then we'd we'd walk set to set and to show Had so many cuts that sometimes people were like God, there's a lot of walking in there.
是的，所有的布景都在舞台上排成一排，然后我们会步行到布景并展示。有太多的剪辑，有时人们就像上帝一样，有很多人在那里行走。
All the little cuts Yeah, and sometimes can't would say we're not moving.
所有的小伤口是的，有时不能说我们不动。
We're just gonna stay here pretend this is the bar We're gonna sit down.
我们就待在这里，假装这是酒吧，我们要坐下来。
It's just two lines We're gonna sit down for many teachers of the bar That's like a year or two to figure out that we needed to like because by the end of some of these executives But by the end of the run through some of these guys are executives were like swearing We want them to be happy cardio in our runthroughs.
这只是两行，我们要为酒吧的许多老师坐下来，这大约需要一两年的时间才能弄清楚我们需要喜欢，因为到这些高管中的一些人结束时，但在这些人中的一些人的运行结束时，高管们就像在发誓，我们希望他们在我们的运行中快乐的有氧运动。
The picture, what we're talking about here, you have a very large stage, stage 22.
图片，我们在这里谈论的，你有一个非常大的舞台，22号舞台。
And just imagine just what you've, everyone, listening has probably seen a set of television, but you have the hero set of the couch, but then just imagine this in the gigantic warehouse, 10, 12, 15 of these little sets, you've got the dentist office, you've got this, you've got that, you've got the small things, which have been built in a day, a couple of days, And then have to be dismantled and replaced with another set often from Wednesday to Thursday once it's shot out on Wednesday.
想象一下，大家可能看过一套电视机，但你有沙发上的英雄套装，但想象一下，在巨大的仓库里，10、12、15个这样的小套装，你有牙医办公室，你有这个，你有那个，你有小东西，这些东西是在一天、几天内建成的，然后必须经常从周三到周三拆除并更换为另一套。周四一旦它在周三被射出。
So it was really our crew, our production crew was unbelievable.
所以这确实是我们的工作人员，我们的制作人员令人难以置信。
The only sets that were there and never got touched were the bar and the apartment.
唯一在那里但从未被触及的布景是酒吧和公寓。
That's it.
就是这样。
Those two were always there.
那两个人一直都在。
And hilariously, like, they're right next door to each other.
有趣的是，他们就在隔壁。
Like they're literally like butted up against each other's own little walkway.
就像他们真的就像在彼此自己的小走道上撞在一起一样。
You could basically walk from one into the other.
你基本上可以从一个走到另一个。
Yeah, it's right.
是的，没错。
They were right there.
他们就在那里。
But everything else would change out.
但其他一切都会改变。
And yeah, the run through would move to these sets.
是的，贯穿将转移到这些集合。
And sometimes the sets were only half built, but we'd be pretending we were fully built during the run through.
有时布景只建了一半，但我们会假装在运行过程中已经完全建好。
And yeah, it was a lot of work.
是的，工作量很大。
So we would do the run through and you'd hear what was working, you'd feel what wasn't quite working.
因此，我们会进行彻底检查，您会听到哪些内容有效，您会感觉到哪些内容不太有效。
And then you guys would huddle up with the network and studio executives, right?
然后你们就会与网络和工作室高管挤在一起，对吧？
And the writers, we would go home.
编剧们，我们会回家。
We would be home.
我们会回家的。
I'd leave it one or one 30 on a Tuesday and have the rest of my day.
我会把周二的一到一点 30 留给它，然后度过余下的一天。
My day was just beginning.
我的一天才刚刚开始。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, we could be given notes by our executives and often very, very smart notes.
是的，我们的高管可以给我们做笔记，而且通常是非常非常聪明的笔记。
We really, we gave ourselves the most notes.
我们真的给自己做了最多的笔记。
You know, we went back, there was stuff we wanted to change.
你知道，我们回去了，有些东西我们想改变。
Like, we'd stay late, not because it was like considered a disaster just because we were like, camera's roll tomorrow morning.
就像，我们会待到很晚，并不是因为这被认为是一场灾难，只是因为我们就像明天早上的相机胶卷一样。
We want to, let's use this time.
我们想要，让我们利用这个时间。
Let's make this as good as we can make it.
让我们尽我们所能把它做到最好。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was it.
就是这样。
But then we'd go rewrite to late at night and that script would go out for me in the morning on a Wednesday and it would get to you.
但后来我们会在深夜重写，剧本会在周三早上给我发给你，然后你就会收到。
And the production assistance would drive it to our house, right?
生产援助会把它送到我们家，对吗？
because maybe later on the run, we finally went email attachments exist.
因为也许在运行之后，我们终于发现了电子邮件附件的存在。
It's not 1925, but I remember somewhere near the end going like, maybe these poor PAs don't need to be driving.
这不是 1925 年，但我记得在接近尾声的某个地方，也许这些可怜的 PA 不需要开车。
But it was for many years of a hard copy show.
但这是多年来的硬拷贝节目。
It was a hard hit, most of the run, most of the run.
这是一个沉重的打击，大部分的奔跑，大部分的奔跑。
And I think even at the end, when we said we're going to switch to emails, I think a few people, a few holdouts for like, I still want to trip into my house.
我想，即使到了最后，当我们说我们要改用电子邮件时，我想还是有一些人，一些坚持不懈的人，我仍然想走进我的房子。
I like getting the hard copy and the PAs were like, oh god damn it.
我喜欢拿到硬拷贝，而 PA 的反应就是，哦，该死的。
So then we, you guys would rewrite all night, we'd get the new script.
然后我们，你们会重写整个晚上，我们会得到新的剧本。
So Wednesday morning, sometimes before I left the house, if I had some time, I would look through, and you're just looking at the start changes, because by that point you know the script pretty well, and you're just looking for what's changed, because you're going to have to shoot it maybe that day.
所以周三早上，有时在我离开家之前，如果我有时间的话，我会仔细查看，而你只是看看开始的变化，因为到那时你已经非常了解剧本了，你只是寻找发生了变化的地方，因为你可能必须在那天拍摄。
So we'd come in Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, we blocked and shot the entire show.
所以我们在周三、周四、周五来，我们封锁并拍摄了整个节目。
We, a lot of people don't know this, I don't know if we talked about this, we never shot in front of a live studio audience where, you know, too many sets, where would you put the bleachers?
我们，很多人不知道这一点，我不知道我们是否谈论过这一点，我们从来没有在现场演播室观众面前拍摄，你知道，太多的布景，你会把露天看台放在哪里？
There's too many damn sets.
该死的套路太多了
So for three days, we would make the show Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
所以三天里，我们会在周三、周四、周五进行演出。
And also, this is another reason why it comes, if you can get one, it's a great way to raise a family because you get one week off a month.
而且，这也是它出现的另一个原因，如果你能得到一个，这是养家糊口的好方法，因为你每个月可以休息一周。
We only do, we do three weeks on one week off, which was pretty cozy, pretty civilized compared to the hours that other.
我们只做，我们每周休息三周，与其他时间相比，这非常舒适，非常文明。
the writers also worked that week, you stung up a bitch.
编剧那周也工作了，你蜇了个婊子。
Sorry.
对不起。
I remember one time, I don't, it was not you, but somebody who was the summer, it was the end of the summer.
我记得有一次，我不记得，那不是你，而是某个夏天，那是夏天的结束。
When we're all coming back to start shooting, we're like, you know, mid August or late August, whenever we started back up.
当我们都回来开始拍摄时，你知道，每当我们开始备份时，我们都会在八月中旬或八月底。
And I remember one of one of you guys, one of the actors who wasn't you asked me like, you know, what did you do?
我记得其中一位演员，一位不是你的演员问我，你知道，你做了什么？
I was in Europe.
我当时在欧洲。
I was here.
我到过这里。
There's what did you do all summer?
整个夏天你都做了什么？
And I was like, we wrote this shit.
我当时想，我们写了这个狗屎。
That's what we did.
这就是我们所做的。
I have not seen the sun.
我还没见过太阳。
I look pale.
我看起来脸色苍白。
I look like sick ET at the end of the movie.
电影结尾时我看起来就像生病的外星人。
I don't I have not been outside during daylight, but I'm glad you enjoyed your trip.
我不知道，我白天没有出去过，但我很高兴你旅途愉快。
You guys always came back looking so beautiful and tan and we're like haggard limping into the start of the marathon.
你们回来时总是看起来那么漂亮，晒黑了，而我们就像在马拉松比赛开始时一瘸一拐地憔悴一样。
But it was, no, it was, it was awesome.
但它是，不，它是，它太棒了。
And we would always come in six, eight scripts ahead and we'd bust our asses during the summer.
我们总是会提前准备六、八个剧本，整个夏天我们都会拼尽全力。
And we got a little, we got a little six week, about four weeks, six weeks in the spring off the writer's day.
我们在春季的作家节休息了一点，六周，大约四个星期，六个星期。
Yeah.
是的。
We had a chance on set because sometimes Mike Shay, our first A.D.
我们有机会在片场，因为有时迈克·谢伊（Mike Shay），我们的第一个 AD。
who's a gem.
谁是宝石。
Hello, Michael.
你好，迈克尔。
We love you if you're listening.
如果你在听，我们爱你。
But he would talk us through the schedule and he'd say, you know, if we can do some real good professional acting on Thursday, we can be out by lunch.
但他会告诉我们时间表，他会说，你知道，如果我们周四能做一些真正出色的专业表演，我们就可以在午餐时出去。
I always say out by lunch.
我总是说午饭前出去。
Out by lunch?
吃午饭就出去吗？
No, but I start, I remember I started it a champ out by lunch and we would all just like turn into Lord of the flies.
不，但我开始了，我记得我在午餐时就开始了它的冠军，我们都想变成蝇王。
Out by the dangling carol.
由悬挂的颂歌出来。
OBL we called it.
我们称之为 OBL。
OBL.
OBL。
Yeah.
是的。
And you did.
你做到了。
And you know, it was, we did work until late, late, late.
你知道，我们一直工作到很晚、很晚、很晚。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
And there was outside night shoots.
还有室外夜景拍摄。
You guys had some very late nights.
你们度过了一些很晚的夜晚。
And we shot the, we shot a lot of scenes in this TV show.
我们拍摄了这个电视节目中的很多场景。
And it was, it was, the Wednesday to Friday was huge for a lot of you guys.
周三到周五对于很多人来说都是重要的一天。
Yeah.
是的。
Most weeks.
大多数星期。
And talk a little bit about New York Street, the one thing that the other main area that is not inside stage 22.
谈谈纽约街，这是不在第 22 阶段内的另一个主要区域的一件事。
It's smaller than people think New York Street on the on the what was in the Fox line.
它比人们想象的福克斯线的纽约街要小。
I guess it's another Disney lot is it's tiny right Josh?
我猜这是另一个迪士尼乐园，它很小吧，乔希？
It's like a little little block a little block like with a little mini turn in it.
它就像一个小块，一个小块，里面有一个小转弯。
It's like a little like a two Ls put together.
有点像两个 L 放在一起。
Yeah and it's we milked the shit out of that thing for nine years to make it look like so many different parts of New York by the end of it.
是的，我们花了九年的时间从​​那东西中榨取了屎，到最后让它看起来像纽约的许多不同地方。
It's like there's no molecule we haven't shot.
就好像我们没有射击过任何分子。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
I always like shooting on New York Street.
我一直喜欢在纽约街头拍摄。
It always I always felt like a field trip.
我总是感觉像是一次实地考察。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Me too.
我也是。
It did.
确实如此。
It felt special.
感觉很特别。
Like a field trip.
就像实地考察一样。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
Yeah.
是的。
We're getting out of school.
我们要放学了
I always, they always would offer to give you a ride, but I always like walking down to New York Street.
我总是，他们总是愿意载你一程，但我总是喜欢步行到纽约街。
Yeah.
是的。
Like it felt like a nice little just head clearing.
感觉就像是一次很好的头脑清醒。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was a nice little walk.
这是一次愉快的散步。
If you'd five to a minute walk to New York Street and it was right up at the front of the Fox lot.
如果你步行五分钟到纽约街，它就在福克斯停车场的前面。
And you'd be standing in this little cute, like sort of little Italy-like lock, right?
你会站在这个可爱的小锁里，就像一把意大利式的小锁，对吧？
It was obviously in Mulberry Street.
显然是在桑树街。
And then you'd look, this cognitive dissonance would happen, and where you'd look one direction and see New York in the other direction and see like palm trees and a blue sky and people talking about it.
然后你会看到，这种认知失调会发生，你朝一个方向看，却在另一个方向看到纽约，看到棕榈树和蓝天，人们在谈论它。
For the flow, it was always very strange, you sometimes lost track over where you were.
对于流程来说，总是很奇怪，有时你会忘记自己在哪里。
Sometimes I felt like I was really there in New York.
有时我感觉自己真的就在纽约。
It was a great, we really made the most of that little street, my God.
真是太棒了，我们真的充分利用了那条小街，天啊。
But there was something about New York street that made me feel like old Hollywood, like Cecil B.
但纽约街头的某些东西让我感觉自己像老好莱坞，就像塞西尔·B.
DeMille, like there was something so grand and fun and fake but not fake about it.
德米尔，就像有一些东西如此宏伟、有趣、虚假，但并不虚假。
Like, it was really cool.
就像，这真的很酷。
I loved it.
我喜欢它。
It felt like PB's big adventure, like that big chase of the blood, where it was like, it gave you the Hollywood you wanted as a kid.
这感觉就像 PB 的大冒险，就像那场热血的大追逐，它给了你小时候想要的好莱坞。
Yes.
是的。
You were going to be part of one day.
你将会成为这一天的一部分。
Exactly.
确切地。
Yeah.
是的。
That's also where Todd runs down the street.
这也是托德沿着街道跑步的地方。
But we'll get to that later.
但我们稍后会讨论这个问题。
I don't remember that.
我不记得了。
We're going to get to that.
我们会做到这一点。
We're going to get to that later.
我们稍后再讨论这个问题。
That's going to talk about that.
那就要讲到这个了。
Amazing.
惊人的。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你。
That is illuminating it.
那就是照亮它。
I think of how this goes.
我想这是怎么回事。
And I want to, we'll keep going back to that sort of bigger questions.
我想，我们将继续回到此类更大的问题。
I want to ask about the writer's room.
我想问一下作家的房间。
I want to ask about all sorts of things.
我想问各种各样的事情。
Let's do a few question number two, I guess.
我想，让我们做一些第二个问题。
A couple of quick ones here.
这里有几个快速的。
A lot of people have questions about where ideas come from.
很多人对想法从何而来有疑问。
And obviously there's the simple answer of, well, we're writers.
显然，答案很简单：我们是作家。
We think of not maybe.
我们认为也许不是。
We think of them.
我们想到他们。
We come up with ideas and then we rewrite them on a piece of paper.
我们提出想法，然后将它们重写在纸上。
You, however, Craig, have said many times that you took from people's lives, whether they're from the writers themselves who said, oh, this happened to me or from your friends and you told them about it or you didn't tell them about it, and we'll get to that as time goes on.
然而，克雷格，你已经说过很多次，你从人们的生活中夺取了一切，无论是来自作家自己，他们说，哦，这件事发生在我身上，还是来自你的朋友，你告诉了他们这件事，或者你没有告诉他们，随着时间的推移，我们会谈到这一点。
So there's a category of question that is, how did you come up with?
所以有一类问题是，你是怎么想出来的？
So many people want to know about the idea of picking up girls at the airport.
很多人想知道去机场接女孩的想法。
Do you recall where this notion came from?
你还记得这个想法是从哪里来的吗？
If you're implying that I did this, the answer is no, I literally think it was just a pun that we liked in the writer's room.
如果你暗示我这样做了，答案是否定的，我真的认为这只是我们在作家房间里喜欢的双关语。
I think it was just the reveal that he's going to pick up girls.
我认为这只是他要泡妞的消息。
It just worked.
它刚刚起作用了。
It was just a great little wordplay joke and we did it.
这只是一个很棒的双关语笑话，我们做到了。
There was nothing.
什么也没有。
There was no real story.
没有真实的故事。
Every now and again, something's just funny.
时不时地，有些事情很有趣。
That was just funny.
那真是太有趣了。
It made us laugh.
这让我们笑了。
So we did it.
所以我们做到了。
It also feels like Barney looks at every setting in the world and thinks how do you pick up girls here?
感觉巴尼看着世界上的每一个地方，并思考如何在这里泡妞？
And he just has a scheme for every one, and this is his airport scheme.
他只是为每个人准备了一个方案，这就是他的机场方案。
This is his airport scheme and he's apparently been doing it long enough that there's might a ton of security camera footage of him doing it.
这是他的机场计划，显然他已经这样做了足够长的时间，以至于可能有大量的安全摄像机镜头记录了他的做法。
Yeah, and I loved, I guess the emotion, the emotion I liked behind it is just how pathetic it kind of is.
是的，我喜欢，我想它背后的情感，我喜欢的情感就是它是多么可悲。
My favorite thing about Barney and rewatching it is just like he's such a broken man.
关于巴尼，我最喜欢的一点是，重看它就像他是一个如此破碎的人。
He's like, you know what I mean?
他就像，你知道我的意思吗？
He's just like in this episode too.
他也像这一集中一样。
He's just like, go along with my idea Ted to show me that I'm important.
他只是同意我的想法，特德，让我知道我很重要。
Show me that I'm special.
让我知道我很特别。
I find it like so like poignant and moving in a way to watch how needy Barney is in these early episodes, like more so than I remember.
我发现巴尼在这些早期剧集中的贫困程度比我记忆中的还要多，这在某种程度上令人心酸和感动。
I haven't watched these ones in a while and just like he just wants Ted to think his idea is cool and go along with it.
我有一段时间没看过这些了，就像他只是想让泰德认为他的想法很酷并同意它一样。
That's it.
就是这样。
He just wants Ted's approval.
他只是想要特德的认可。
It's I have the experience watching it where I felt like I wish Ted was a little more game And I wish Barney would be a little less excited.
我有观看它的经验，我觉得我希望泰德能多一点游戏性，我希望巴尼能少一点兴奋。
Like, I know that that's where the drama comes from, but just like watching almost like me or this avatar of me, I was like, you should go along with this, this could be fun, like just like that.
就像，我知道这就是戏剧的来源，但就像像我一样观看或我的化身，我想，你应该同意这一点，这可能很有趣，就像那样。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Not when he's drinking my tart lemonade in the basement, you know, at that point he's over it.
不是当他在地下室喝我的酸柠檬水的时候，你知道，那时他就已经喝完了。
But yeah, I mean, I think, I think we got there a little later, I think we got there more later.
但是，是的，我的意思是，我想，我想我们到达那里晚了一点，我想我们到达那里更晚了。
We got some more later.
后来我们又得到了一些。
He has fun with us too.
他也和我们一起玩得很开心。
is some of the best nights of his life are created by this madman and it's better to just go along with them.
他一生中最美好的一些夜晚都是这个疯子创造的，最好顺其自然。
Yeah.
是的。
What I was struck with was, is Barney successful at doing this?
让我震惊的是，巴尼成功做到了这一点吗？
Like that's what I, I feel like later in this series, you get the sense that he, he is, he is.
就像这就是我，我觉得在这个系列的后面，你会感觉到他，他是，他是。
He does get, he does get the ladies.
他确实得到了，他确实得到了女士们。
But in this one, I was like, oh, early on, it's possible he doesn't.
但在这一次，我想，哦，一开始，他可能不会。
It's possible.
这是有可能的。
These are all just games.
这些都只是游戏。
In episode one, he's playing laser tag with preteens.
在第一集中，他正在和青春期前的孩子玩激光枪战。
And episode two, he seems to hook up with one girl in those series of parties.
在第二集中，他似乎在一系列聚会中勾搭上了一个女孩。
In episode three, he's just back to just not really, not really scoring any with any layies.
在第三集中，他只是回到了不真正、不真正与任何外行得分的状态。
He's not really doing anything that impressive.
他并没有真正做任何令人印象深刻的事情。
Sometimes you see him with an actual woman, but a lot of times it's just a story.
有时你会看到他和一个真正的女人在一起，但很多时候这只是一个故事。
He's telling.
他在说。
I think it's.
我认为是的。
Yeah.
是的。
And I would guess that 75 to 80% of his stories are either fabricated or a kernel of truth.
我猜他的故事 75% 到 80% 要么是捏造的，要么是真实的。
You know, kernel of truth.
你知道，真理的核心。
truth.
真相。
Colonel truth.
真相上校。
That's the bonus one, that's the bonus one of bonus.
这是奖金之一，这是奖金的奖金之一。
We got there.
我们到了那里。
That's why you remember we initiated general knowledge.
这就是为什么你记得我们发起了常识。
We said we're going to get to this one and it is fucking happened.
我们说过我们会解决这个问题，但它确实发生了。
It's that no unplanned.
这并不是无计划的。
Well, that was just too.
嗯，那也是。
That was so lucky.
那真是太幸运了。
You are lucky.
你很幸运。
You are listening.
你正在听。
I felt my way to that.
我摸索着做到了这一点。
Just intuitively.
只是凭直觉。
Colonel of knowledge.
知识上校。
Colonel truth.
真相上校。
Colonel of knowledge.
知识上校。
Yeah.
是的。
That's good.
那挺好的。
When you find those in nature, it's just so good.
当你在大自然中找到这些时，那就太好了。
Okay.
好的。
I forgot we're talking about the next question.
我忘了我们正在讨论下一个问题。
Well, Josh, I think people really loved the interrogation scene because there were multiple questions and I'll press it.
好吧，乔什，我认为人们真的很喜欢审讯场景，因为有很多问题，我会按它。
That scene is so funny.
那场面真是太搞笑了。
It's so good.
太好了。
I'll credit Mad Candy, what, oh, Mad Candy Hatter and Hazard Hanson for questions like this.
我会把这样的问题归功于 Mad Candy，什么，哦，Mad Candy Hatter 和 Hazard Hanson。
How many takes it, how many takes did it take for you and Neil in the police room scene?
你和尼尔在警察室的场景拍了多少次？
or how hard it was it for you to not break on set.
或者你在片场不崩溃是多么困难。
People obviously love bloopers.
人们显然喜欢花哨的事情。
They also just love hearing about the notion of bloopers.
他们也喜欢听到花哨的概念。
And so hard to fashion a real question around this, but it looked like you were having fun.
很难围绕这个提出一个真正的问题，但看起来你玩得很开心。
Were you breaking a lot?
你打破了很多吗？
I think that that's a pretty strong blooper presence in episode season one bloopers.
我认为这在第一季的花絮中是一个相当强烈的花絮。
Yeah.
是的。
Because Neil, he definitely was making me laugh with we are international just doubling tripling and quadrupling down on that.
因为尼尔，他肯定让我笑了，我们是国际化的，只是在这方面投入了三倍和四倍的努力。
That really made me laugh watching again.
这真的让我再次观看时笑了。
I do remember in the run-throughs and even when we were shooting it, the thing about the shirt, you know, the untucked shirt and his looks to me.
我确实记得在演练中，甚至在我们拍摄的时候，关于衬衫的事情，你知道，衬衫没有塞进裤腰，还有他对我的看法。
And I felt like, I felt like we were, like Laurel and Hardy or Abyn Costello.
我觉得，我觉得我们就像劳雷尔和哈代或艾宾·科斯特洛。
Road trip movie.
公路旅行电影。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It was just like, it felt like we were a new kind of like classic vaudeville team.
感觉就像我们是一支新的经典杂耍团队。
Definitely.
确实。
Where we were just had a bit and he had his character I had my character, it was really interesting to see Ted, in the first two episodes, Ted is the driver, he's got his foot on the accelerator, and in this one, he's a reactor, Barney is the driver, and I think I was really trying to navigate how to be, if I was directing myself again, I would have been like lighten this up, it's a little too bummed, and I just I wish I had had like a little smile.
我们只是有一点，他有他的角色，我有我的角色，看到特德真的很有趣，在前两集中，特德是司机，他把脚踩在加速器上，而在这一集里，他是一个反应堆，巴尼是司机，我想我真的在努力导航如何成为，如果我再次指导自己，我会喜欢减轻这一点，这有点太令人失望了，我只是希望我有一个像小微笑。
I think it's a great look.
我认为这看起来很棒。
We can fix it in post.
我们可以在后期修复它。
It's not too heavy.
不太重。
You can get back in there.
你可以回到那里。
I think I was too bummed out by him and I think I should just been like, you know, some of that's the writing though as you point out because we could have written that I agree with that.
我想我对他太失望了，我想我应该说，你知道，其中一些是你指出的，因为我们可以写下我同意这一点。
I agree with that as a writing note, too.
我也同意作为书面笔记的这一点。
Look, we could have, and I think we found that I think we're like, we found out where we went on.
听着，我们本来可以，我想我们发现我们就像，我们发现了我们继续前进的方向。
There's a little exaggerated in this one because you had to figure out why do they keep paying out with this guy.
这有点夸张，因为你必须弄清楚为什么他们一直和这个家伙付钱。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, the last line of the narration of the episode does sort of fit to that, which is great.
嗯，这一集旁白的最后一行确实符合这一点，这很棒。
And that was the question we were trying to answer.
这就是我们试图回答的问题。
And the episode was like, why do they hang out with this guy?
这一集就像是，为什么他们和这个家伙一起出去玩？
And that was the answer at the end of that episode.
这就是该集结尾处的答案。
Yeah.
是的。
But I remember Chris and Phil, Chris Miller Phil Lorde, wonderful writers wrote that episode.
但我记得克里斯和菲尔，克里斯·米勒，菲尔·洛德，出色的作家写了这一集。
They would refer to it as, when they went up to script, they said, we're going to write this as a Barney cartoon.
他们将其称为，当他们开始编写剧本时，他们说，我们要把它写成巴尼卡通。
That was the phrase that always second man.
这就是永远第二人的那句话。
We're going to write a Barney cartoon.
我们要写一部巴尼漫画。
They're the men.
他们是男人。
The brilliant minds who brought you the Lego movies and Cloudy, the Chesapeake Bulls, they are cartoon guys.
为您带来乐高电影和切萨皮克公牛队 Cloudy 的聪明人，他们都是卡通人物。
They are animation guys.
他们是动画人。
And they said, is it okay if we push Barney to this place of being this cartoon, Ted gets sucked into it.
他们说，如果我们把巴尼推到这个卡通的地方，泰德就会被卷进去，这样可以吗？
And it's like he's sort of the voice of reason within.
就好像他是内心理性的声音。
He's sort of the human being interacting with an animated character.
他有点像人类与动画角色互动。
And they push that, they sort of, that's where we first got legendary.
他们推动了这一点，这就是我们第一次获得传奇的地方。
That's where we got the lactose intolerant joke.
这就是我们得到乳糖不耐症笑话的地方。
That's that script is where we got all that stuff.
这就是我们获得所有这些东西的脚本。
And Barney climbing out of the suitcase that he zipped himself into on the baggage claim.
巴尼从行李箱里爬出来，在行李认领处把自己拉上拉链。
And apparently that worked.
显然这有效。
Apparently that got him the girl, but is that actually the truth?
显然这让他得到了那个女孩，但这真的是事实吗？
Who knows?
谁知道？
I do want to know the backstory of what he said to the woman about why he was inside the city.
我确实想知道他对那个女人说的关于他为什么在城里的背景故事。
But that's the beginning of his like mastery of disguise.
但这是他伪装技巧的开始。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
Yeah.
是的。
And they really they ran with that.
他们确实这么做了。
They just make it a cartoon and it was also great how you guys be to pay off legend, wait for it.
他们只是把它拍成动画片，你们为传奇付出代价也很棒，等待吧。
I don't hope you're not lactose intolerant because the next part of this phrase is dairy or whatever.
我不希望你没有乳糖不耐症，因为这句话的下一部分是乳制品或其他什么。
I don't know if I missed go to that, right?
不知道我是否错过了，对吧？
But you said legendary about 12 to 15 times to set that up.
但你说了大约 12 到 15 次传奇来设置它。
Like it was literally just, it's really saying legendary to set up that last punch.
就像字面上的意思一样，最后一拳的设置确实是传奇。
It really is.
确实如此。
It's all there to get to that joke.
这一切都是为了讲那个笑话。
Yeah, it's all there to get to that joke.
是的，这一切都是为了开那个玩笑。
And then that became this catchphrase for Barney that sort of echoed through eternity.
然后这成为了巴尼的口号，在永恒中回响。
But it was really, yeah, you're right.
但这确实是，是的，你是对的。
We wrote that as setups to get to that one joke.
我们写这个是为了达到那个笑话的目的。
And then it took off because I don't know if he said legendary in the first two episodes.
然后它就开始流行了，因为我不知道他在前两集中是否说过传奇。
He definitely didn't.
他绝对没有。
He definitely didn't because I feel like Chris and Phil brought that in with them by writing their Barney cartoon.
他绝对没有，因为我觉得克里斯和菲尔通过写他们的巴尼卡通片把这一点带进来了。
I feel like that was very much them and that lactose intolerant joke was very much, I mean, their names are on the script obviously, but it's very also very collaborative.
我觉得这就是他们的风格，乳糖不耐症的笑话非常多，我的意思是，他们的名字显然在剧本上，但它也非常合作。
But they really came in with a lot of that sort of like fun Barney speak.
但他们确实带来了很多类似巴尼所说的有趣的东西。
They really, they really like helped define that in the show and I'll be forever grateful to them for that.
他们真的非常喜欢在节目中帮助定义这一点，我将永远感激他们。
Didn't they also bring in the term mind hole?
他们不是还引入了“心灵洞”这个词吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I think mind hole.
我觉得脑子有洞。
They had their own language.
他们有自己的语言。
Chris and Phil had their own language.
克里斯和菲尔有自己的语言。
There's a few lines in that episode where I'm just like only Kristen Phil, like where he's like Barney asked the guy, like, do you ever touch the Liberty Bell and the guy goes, only all the time.
在那一集里有几句台词，我就像克里斯汀·菲尔一样，就像他就像巴尼问那个人，比如，你有没有碰过自由钟，然后那个人就走了，只是一直。
That's like the phrase only all the time.
这就像这句话，一直都是这样。
I'm like, that's Kristen Phil.
我想，那是克里斯汀·菲尔。
I can't tell you why, only all the time.
我无法告诉你为什么，只能一直告诉你。
I love it so much.
我非常喜欢它。
Can I say I know there were a lot of questions about licking Liberty Bell and we don't know.
我可以说我知道有很多关于舔自由钟的问题，但我们不知道。
I don't know where that came from, but I did write a tweet I think years ago.
我不知道那是从哪里来的，但我记得几年前我确实写过一条推文。
This is many years ago, while the show was still on, where I said, I'm genuinely curious how many security guards at the Liberty Bell have had to stop himium fans from trying to lick it or throwing them out for licking it, because there had to have been an increase at the very least in attempts from zero percent to zero percent, like a couple, they have to, right?
这是很多年前的事了，当节目还在播出时，我说过，我真的很好奇自由钟有多少保安不得不阻止那些试图舔它的人，或者因为舔它而把他们扔出去，因为至少尝试次数必须从百分之零增加到百分之零，就像一对夫妇一样，他们必须这样做，对吧？
so curious, we should get a Liberty Bell security guard as a guest.
很好奇，我们应该请一位自由钟保安作为客人。
We invite, did you invite any fans to write us, you know, write us if they ever got.
我们邀请，你邀请任何粉丝给我们写信吗，你知道，如果有的话，给我们写信。
If anyone ever licked the Liberty Bell, we want to hear from you.
如果有人曾舔过自由钟，我们希望收到您的来信。
Yeah, I feel like I've sought some tweets at some point where people claim to have actually done it.
是的，我觉得我在某些时候寻找过一些人们声称实际上已经做到了的推文。
Like they knew somebody that worked there and they had their, they wanted to go do the how I met your mother thing and they did it.
就像他们认识在那里工作的人并且他们有自己的一样，他们想要去做我如何认识你母亲的事情，他们做到了。
I feel like I saw a couple of people that did do it somehow.
我觉得我看到有几个人确实以某种方式做到了这一点。
I feel like, I mean, we both would have to, and so wouldn't want to ask for proof.
我觉得，我的意思是，我们都必须这样做，所以不想要求证据。
I also think it's another, like Barney is addicted to novelty, right?
我也认为这是另一回事，就像巴尼沉迷于新奇一样，对吧？
Like, he's addicted to newness and weirdness and no one's ever done this before and won't we, like he's a pioneer, right?
就像，他沉迷于新鲜和怪异，以前没有人这样做过，我们不会，就像他是先驱一样，对吧？
Like, he wants to come up with the weirdest stuff, so he can say we did this first, you know?
就像，他想想出最奇怪的东西，所以他可以说我们先做了这个，你知道吗？
a charming, if reckless quality of him, you know, it's very, I found it very endearing because it's like, you know, Barney, they're, Barney has some dark sides and some troubling sides, but he really just wants to be sped, thought of a special.
他有一种迷人的，尽管鲁莽的品质，你知道，这非常，我发现它非常可爱，因为这就像，你知道，巴尼，他们，巴尼有一些黑暗的一面和一些令人不安的一面，但他真的只是想被加速，想到一个特别的。
He wants to be important to his friends.
他想对他的朋友很重要。
And also the epic part of that story did not involve having sex with women.
而且这个故事的史诗部分并不涉及与女性发生性关系。
It involved licking the Liberty Bell.
它涉及舔自由钟。
Like this is very strange out there thing.
这在外面是很奇怪的事情。
It's not always hooking up.
它并不总是连接在一起。
Sometimes it's just doing something that nobody else has ever done.
有时它只是做一些别人从未做过的事情。
Yeah, I like that too.
是的，我也喜欢这样。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, we've answered many people, of course, wanted to point it out and enjoyed pointing out this is the birthplace of legendary.
好吧，我们已经回答了很多人，当然，想要指出这一点并且很高兴指出这是传奇的诞生地。
So thank you for covering that and with credit, I guess, to Chris and Phil for that.
因此，感谢您对此进行报道，我想，这要归功于克里斯和菲尔。
But finally, fans do love pointing out breaks in logic all these many years later.
但最后，粉丝们确实喜欢在多年后指出逻辑上的突破。
And I filter those out because you know, you're just writing a TV show.
我把它们过滤掉，因为你知道，你只是在写一个电视节目。
But I enjoyed that Sarah Frazier 44 did say how was there time for a beverage service on a flight from New York City?
但我很高兴 Sarah Frazier 44 确实说过从纽约市起飞的航班上有时间提供饮料服务吗？
That's actually a great question.
这实际上是一个很好的问题。
I wasn't prepared to be annoyed by this question and I'm like, Sarah, great question.
我没准备好被这个问题惹恼，我想，莎拉，这是个好问题。
That's a good one.
这是一件好事。
They were circling for a while because they couldn't get it.
他们绕了好一会儿，因为找不到。
But also, you've got to be able to see in a talk about that.
而且，你必须能够在演讲中看到这一点。
They fly Marshall drives.
他们驾驶马歇尔驾驶。
He's probably getting there before like you could drive to Philly quicker than you could fly to Philly.
他可能会提前到达那里，就像你开车去费城比坐飞机去费城更快一样。
It's totally true.
这是完全正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
All right.
好的。
Busted.
被抓了。
They blessed us on the drink service.
他们为我们提供了饮料服务。
We till we'll take the head on that one.
我们直到我们能拿下那个人的头。
And that's it folks.
就是这样，伙计们。
Thank you so much for sending in your questions there on Instagram.
非常感谢您在 Instagram 上发送问题。
We're going to keep on soliciting those from you on Instagram.
我们将继续在 Instagram 上征求您的意见。
So if you want to send in your questions, do go there and send them to us any any final thoughts in this bonus episode of whatever the name of this is.
因此，如果您想提出您的问题，请前往那里，并将此奖金集中的任何最终想法（无论其名称是什么）发送给我们。
I don't keep names of things in my head.
我不会把事物的名字记在脑子里。
Sweet taste of sweet pal sweet taste of liberty.
甜蜜朋友的甜蜜味道，自由的甜蜜味道。
That's a great dance to liberty.
这是一场伟大的自由之舞。
Um, yeah, I don't know, it was, it was just, it was a fun one, it was, it was a fun other move.
嗯，是的，我不知道，这是，这只是，这是一个有趣的举动，这是，这是另一个有趣的举动。
It was the one where we started to discover Barney a little more.
正是从那时起，我们开始更多地了解巴尼。
I love how the first two, the first two really felt like an hour to me.
我喜欢前两个，前两个对我来说真的感觉就像一个小时。
Didn't we talk about that Josh?
我们不是讨论过乔希吗？
Like, it really felt like they, they just belong together.
就像，真的感觉他们就像属于在一起一样。
It was like an hour long story about this guy named Ted.
这就像一个关于这个名叫特德的人的长达一个小时的故事。
And then this is the episode where it's like, also, there's this speed.
然后这一集也有这样的速度。
There's this other move in this other move of this show will be this crazy guy Barney drags people on these insane adventures.
这个节目的另一个动作是这个疯狂的家伙巴尼拖着人们进行这些疯狂的冒险。
Obviously we're trying to like pair up Lily and Robin and sort of show that like our ladies will hang out.
显然，我们试图让莉莉和罗宾配对，并举办一些像我们的女士们会一起出去玩的节目。
They're just becoming friends.
他们只是成为朋友。
Well, um, so I like that it was showing other moves also as the show, this show starts here and it keeps widening at spotlight.
嗯，嗯，所以我喜欢它在表演时也展示了其他动作，这个表演从这里开始，并且在聚光灯下不断扩大。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, and you're like Carl the bartender's over here and Wendy the waitress is over here and these people, Hammond Rothers is over here like it keeps spotlighting different and it keeps expanding its universe in a really cool way and this was definitely where I think you're right, you have to explain why do they hang out with this guy, and it's because they never know where the night is going.
你知道，你就像调酒师卡尔在这里，女服务员温迪在这里，这些人，哈蒙德罗瑟斯在这里，就像它不断地聚焦不同的东西，它不断以一种非常酷的方式扩展它的宇宙，这绝对是我认为你是对的，你必须解释为什么他们和这个家伙一起出去玩，因为他们永远不知道夜晚会去哪里。
And also, you know, Ted's insistence, like, I just want to be with the same bar, same drink, same palsy friends right below my apartment, and he's, he nudges him out of his comfort zone and it's like, we need friends like that.
而且，你知道，特德的坚持，就像，我只想和我公寓楼下的同一个酒吧，同一个饮料，同一个麻痹朋友在一起，而他，他把他推出了他的舒适区，就像，我们需要这样的朋友。
Yeah, Bernie has value, he's a good friend.
是的，伯尼很有价值，他是一个好朋友。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪孽都被宽恕。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Webb 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Pointe de Blue Studios, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Pointe de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Morrow 创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的 NYC，特别感谢 Lowly Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters Unsubstack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasWriter.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的时事通讯 Unsubstack，阅读克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上发表的散文，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死亡父亲协会》(Dead Fathers Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下得以实现，营销由 Tink Media 提供。
but will, in fact, dance.
但事实上，他会跳舞。